[Musik]
maximale Anspannung hier auch
visualpolitik haben wir euch bereits
erzählt dass die Beziehungen zwischen
Washington und Riad nicht gerade der
reibungslos verlaufen tatsächlich
befinden sie sich seit Jahren in einer
Flaute und die Dinge dann eher
schlechter als besser das alte Bündnis
die besondere Beziehung zwischen Richard
und Washington gehört der Vergangenheit
an und den Grund dafür veranschaulicht
diese Grafik perfekt wir haben schon oft
darüber gesprochen Jahrzehnte lang
garantierte Washington die Sicherheit
des saudischen Königshauses als
Gegenleistung für die reichhaltigen
Öllieferung des Landes an den Weltmarkt
und auch an der Wolf verdiente man
prächtig angeschafft mit den Retro
Dollars es war so etwas wie eine
vernünftige und die kann manchmal besser
funktionieren als eine liebesheiratet
keine gegenseitiger verteidigungsvertrag
oder Pakt verbindet die Vereinigten
Staaten mit Saudi-Arabien und historisch
hat sie auch nie eine verbunden aber
trotzdem waren alle fest davon überzeugt
dass im Falle von Problemen die
Vereinigten Staaten der Saudi Dynastie
zu Hilfe geeignet wäre selbst wenn dies
bedeutet hätte dass sie ihre ganze
militärische Stärke einsetzen müssten
ganz zu schweigen von den Tausenden von
us-militärberatern die das saudische
Militär ausgebildet und in der Praxis
unterstützt haben
[Musik]
doch die Fracking Revolution hat alles
verändert plötzlich waren die
Vereinigten Staaten beim Erdöl fast und
man könnte sagen dass die USA von da an
den Nahen Osten mit anderen Augen sagen
es war dann nur eine Frage der Zeit bis
es zum ersten Ehekrach kam aber das
haben wir bereits in einem früheren
Video behandelt dass ich euch in der
Beschreibung verlinken werde die Frage
ist also warum wir hier auf Politik
schon wieder über Saudi Arabien und die
Vereinigten Staaten sprechen
[Musik]
nun ja weil es wieder einen Ehekrach
gibt und zwar ein so großen wie nie
zuvor was ist passiert nun die
arabischen Ölpreis haben die
wiederholten Bitten des Weißen Hauses
ignoriert und am 5 Oktober dieses Jahres
eine energiepolitische Bombe gezündet
OPEC plus verschärft die größte
ölförderkürzung seit Beginn der Pandemie
die Reduzierung der täglichen
Fördermenge um 2 Millionen Barrel dürfte
die Preise in die Höhe treiben und
Moskau helfen gut dass die ope mal die
Förderquoten hebt und dann wieder sind
ist nicht zu ungewöhnlich allerdings
haben sich die Zeiten geändert heute ist
alles anders einerseits haben die
Energiekrise und ihrem Barcode im Öl und
Gashandel mit Russland den Persischen
Golf wieder zu einem unverzichtbaren
Lieferanten für den besten gemacht so
sind die europäischen gassenöl Importe
aus dem Golf in weniger als einem Jahr
von rund 10 % auf mehr als 20% gestiegen
das heißt die haben sich über wenigen
Monaten verdoppelt und das verleitet den
Scheiß eine enorme Marktmacht die Petra
Monarchien wissen das und wollen es
jetzt ausnutzen im Moment braucht jeder
das Öl vom Golf jeder braucht Saudi
Arabien und die vi einige Leute
Washington begreifen definitiv nicht das
ist einen neuen Golf gibt und dass wir
keine Befehle mehr von Washington
entgegennehmen und das liebe
visualpolitikzuschauer ist keine
Bagatelle
geldströmt in den Persischen Golf wir
sprechen von hunderten von Milliarden
Dollar zusätzlich konkret spricht der
IWF von einem einnahmeüberschuss für die
Exporteure in Nahen Osten und den
Zentralasien in Höhe von 320 Milliarden
Dollar und das ist nur die Rechnung für
das aktuelle Jahr 2022 aber während die
Scheiße in der Vergangenheit auch nicht
so ganz hohe Ölpreise setzen um die
Fracking Produzenten zu bestrafen sieht
es jetzt ganz anders aus sagen wir
einfach dass die saudies ihre Kassen so
schnell wie möglich wieder auffüllen
wollen und genau das tun sie in sich
versuchen den Preis für einen brennt
über 100 Dollar zu halten aber auch wenn
Ihnen das nicht mehr wirklich gelingt
der Punkt ist dass dieser Wucher mit dem
Ölpreis nicht die einzige ökonomische
und politische Konsequenz ist es gibt
noch eine weitere die direkt mit Moskau
zu tun hat denn die von der OPEC plus
beschlossene Maßnahme die weltweite
Produktion 2 Millionen zu kürzen ist ein
echter Schub für den Kremmen solche
Maßnahmen bekommt Putin gerade Recht vor
allem in Zeiten der christlichen in der
EU und von der G7 beschlossenen Preis
Obergrenze führungszeug auf diese kommen
wir später dann noch zurück die Frage
ist also führen die scheiß eine
gigantische Rettungsaktion für Russland
durch
heute werden wir diese Frage in alle
Ausführlichkeit beantworten und zwar
gleich nach einem kleinen Werbehinweis
unseres Sponsors nordpass jeder von uns
muss dauernd mit einem Haufen von
Passwörtern umgehenden ein und dasselbe
Passwort für mehrere Sachen zu verwenden
ist die Ursünde der IT-Sicherheit
schlechthin nordpass hilft ein jedoch
dabei dass man so viele Passwörter haben
kann wie nötig der Umgang mit ihnen
jedoch so einfach ist wie mit nur einem
einzigen mit nordpass kannst du
automatisch sichere Passwörter für jeden
Zweck erstellen und sie in einem Ort
speichern ohne dass du sie dir merken
musst egal ob es um Webseite Anwendungen
oder Kreditkarten geht es bietet dabei
ein Sicherheitslevel und gleichzeitig
kommt vor der weit über standarddienste
hinausgeht zum Beispiel kannst du deine
Passwörter durch Biometrie schützen und
die zugehörigen Webseite direkt
anspringen das ist plattformübergreifend
alle deine Geräte auch PC oder Handy
unterstützt versteht sich von selbst
aber nicht nur das nordpass geht noch
einen Schritt weiter und schützt deinen
Daten nicht nur passiv sondern mit einem
ganzen Arsenal von security features
Premium scannt zum Beispiel das Internet
kontinuierlich nach deinen Daten und
findet heraus ob diese nicht
möglicherweise gelegt wurden und falls
dies der Fall sein sollte wann es dich
so dass du rechtzeitig reagieren und die
Gefahr bannen kannst bevor schlimmeres
Unglück hereinbricht und das Beste für
die visualpolitik Community hat noch
Pass eine ganz besondere Aktion in petto
bei Abschluss eines zweijahres Abos
bekommst du einen Monat kostenlos dazu
wenn du beim Check auch den Code
sowieso.de angibst den Link findest du
in der Beschreibung unter diesem Video
natürlich kannst du alles in Ruhe
unverbindliche völlig unrisiko
Ausprobieren der nordpass kommt mit
einer 30 tägigen Geld zurück Garantie
falls es Dich bis dahin nicht von seinen
Vorzügen überzeugt haben sollte also
nicht viel los besorgt euch nordpassung
greift damit auch gleichzeitig uns
finanziell unter die Arme das könnt ihr
übrigens auch direkt mit Hilfe des
Spenden links ebenfalls in die
Beschreibung gepackt haben wir sind euch
für jede Unterstützung
in Zukunft noch mehr und noch bessere
Videos zu liefern so und nun ab an dem
Golf und zur Frage helfen die scheiß
Putin wirklich aus der Patsche
Wut in Washington
in Washington und vor allem im Weißen
Haus ist man not amused denn für die
Amerikaner schreibt es ganz klar die
Saudis waren die Hauptverantwortlichen
für die Entscheidung der Oper die
Ölproduktion zu drosseln dass die Araber
dies auch noch kurz vor dem zwischenwahl
in den USA Taten und zu einem Zeitpunkt
an den Putins Regine ukrainischen
militärisch versagte betrachten sie fast
als Erpressung aber für einige
Beobachter kam es dann doch nicht so
überraschen denn während des
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf 2020 sagte
dass Saudi Arabien ein paar realstaat
sein es war die Antwort des heutigen
Präsidenten auf dem brutalen Nord am
journalistischer er wollte sich damit
auch von seinem Rivalen Trump Absetzen
der mit den Sony ist ja eine enge
Freundschaft aufgebaut hatte nach dem
Motto was Trump tut muss schlecht sein
der russische Überfall auf die Ukraine
Zwang beide jedoch in den saueren Apfel
zu beißen der besten wollte den Krempel
bestrafen indem er die ölkäufe zu großen
Teil einstellte und dafür mussten
plötzlich alternative Lieferanten her
aber das war nicht so einfach wie
gedacht nach Jahren der unter
Investition in der Branche war der
Gasmarkt furchtbar angespannt wir haben
darüber ein Video auf unserem
schwesterkanal visual economic gedreht
dass ich euch verlinken werde auf jeden
Fall musste sich der US-Präsident und
viele andere führende Politiker weltweit
auf die Suche nach alternativen Quellen
machen auf dem Weg dorthin war
Washington sogar bereit Ländern wie den
Iran und Venezuela die Hand zu erreichen
bislang übrigens mit ziemlich
bescheidenen Ergebnissen
tatsache ist dass die großen
Ölproduzenten am Golf wieder einmal zu
den Hauptakteuren in dieser ganzen
Energie politischen Saga geworden sind
und so besuchte Joe Biden mit juli
Mohammed bin Salman in Saudi Arabien es
war nicht das freundlichste und
herzlichste Treffen der Welt aber die
Geste Schienen wie ein Wendepunkt in den
Beziehungen zu sein das Weiße Haus war
bereit die Beziehungen wieder
aufzunehmen wenn sie hat sich aktiv an
der großen internationalen Koalition
gegen Russland beteiligen würde oder
zumindest Schritte Unternehmer um die
Ölpreise und damit im Teil des
Inflationsdrucks abzukühlen der die
halbe Welt so schwer belastet
aber nur zweieinhalb Monate nach diesem
Besuch bestätigte sich was viele schon
vermutet hatten dass die Reise ein
kompletter Fehlschlag gewesen war weit
davon entfernt eine Erhöhung der
Produktion zu erwirken hat die OPEC plus
angeführt von Saudi-Arabien und Russland
selbst sogar das Gegenteil getan und ihr
könnt mir glauben dass das den Zorn
Washingtons auf sich gezogen hat vor
allem weil du 5 Tage vor der Ankündigung
der Maßnahme Abgesandte des Weißen
Hauses nach riapreisten um die Regierung
von Mohammed zu bitten genau dies nicht
zu tun aber alles war vergeblich
natürlich diesen Reaktion nicht lange
auf sich warten
Naturen darunter Robert Mendes der
Vorsitzende des mächtigsten
Senatsausschusses für auswärtige
Beziehungen forderte bereits ein
Einfrieren jeglicher Zusammenarbeit mit
Saudi-Arabien einschließlich der
militärischen Zusammenarbeit außerdem
haben mehrere Naturen und
Kongressabgeordnete sowohl Demokraten
als auch Republikaner angekündigt sich
für neue Gesetze einzusetzen die
waffenverkäufer anders arabische Land
verbieten und es steht sogar die
Möglichkeit im Raum das sowohl das Weiße
Haus als auch der Kongress selbst das
sogenannte Moped gesetzt aktiviert
dieses Gesetz zieht darauf auf
Ölunternehmen im Besitz und Regierung
kartellrechtlich zu verfolgen und zu
bestrafen das Gesetz existiert als
Vorlage damals unter Trump entworfen es
wurde aber nie verabschiedet ohne allzu
sehr in die Tiefe zu gehen wenn dieses
Gesetz in Kraft treten würde dann würde
es genau auf Aramco Zielen den allen
mächtigen saudischen ölkonzept
das Weiße Haus selbst scheint nun bereit
zu sein nicht nur seine Außenpolitik
gegenüber Ria zu ändern sondern auch
seine eigene Energiepolitik für die
Vereinigten Staaten wenn die Regierung
beiden bisher der Energiewende Priorität
eingeräumt hat könnte sich das jetzt
wieder komplett ändern um es klar zu
sagen Tracking ist wieder in Mode wir
werden mit unseren US Verbündeten
zusammenarbeiten um die Produktion zu
erhöhen und sicherzustellen dass über
ausreichende raffinerikapazitäten
verfügen wenn eines glasklar ist dann
dass die Entscheidung der ope Plus für
die westlichen auswirkschaften und
insbesondere für das alte Europa noch
mehr Schmerzen bedeutete
die schlimmste Folge der Drosselung der
Ölproduktion ist aber das ist Russland
hilft es wirkt wie eine Rettungsleine
für Putin dessen Armee in der Ukraine
militärisch gesehen ja ein Desaster
durchmachen die Entscheidung des Audi
ist wirkt wie ein Druckmittel gegen den
besten zu einer Zeit und das alles macht
es schlimmer viel viel schlimmer sieht
her was man in Washington davon hält was
Saudi Arabien getan hat um Putin dabei
helfen seinen verabscheuungswürdigen und
bösartigen Krieg gegen die Ukraine
vorzusetzen wird den Amerikanern lange
in Erinnerung bleiben wir sehen keinen
Grund warum amerikanische Truppen und
Auftragnehmer weiterhin diesen Dienst
für Länder leisten sollten die aktiv
gegen uns arbeiten wenn Saudi-Arabien
und die VR Putin helfen wollen sollten
Sie sich an ihn wenden wenn es um ihre
Verteidigung geht und das wird die Frage
auf ob die OPEC wirklich Putins Russland
unterstützt wird gut so
die Umarmung des russischen Bären
beim opec-plus-treffen in Wien bei dem
die produktionskürzung beschlossen wurde
gab es zwei wichtige Akteure der
saudische Energieminister Salman und der
stellvertretende Ministerpräsident von
Russland Alexander Nowak ein Mann der
nur wenige Tage zuvor von den
Vereinigten Staaten sanktioniert wurden
die Anwesenheit des stellvertretenden
russischen Ministerpräsidenten der US
Sanktion steht um über die Verknappung
des ölangebots vor einem Winter zu
sprechen in dem Russland seine
gasexporter nach Europa bereits als
Waffe eingesetzt hat sendet eine klare
Botschaft und ist klar zu sagen
bestehen darauf dass die Drosselung der
Produktion keine politische Frage ist
sondern eine reine geschäftliche eines
ist jedoch ganz klar die Golfstaaten
haben den russischen Überfall der
Ukraine nicht verurteilt und keine
Sanktionen unterstützt und jetzt haben
sie auch noch nicht auf die inständigen
Bitten der USA ihres eigentlich
Verbündeten gehört immerhin Beton erst
kürzlich als Angriffs Iran gegen Saudi
Arabien kursierten an verdi hat als
natürliche Verbündeter militärisch zur
Seite was aber tun die soundies im
Gegenzug und sie haben immerhin bei
einem Gefangenenaustausch vermittelt bei
dem die USA und Russland einen
Waffenhändler gegen eine Basketballerin
getauscht haben solche
boulevardnachrichten dürfen und sie doch
nicht davon ablenken eine Tatsache zu
übersehen das Land das bei weitem am
meisten von den opa-produktionsgrößern
profitiert hat ist ausgerechnet Putins
Russland und warum nun lasst mich das
erklären
im Gegensatz zu Saudi-Arabien den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten den Irak
oder sind die russischen ölförderkosten
sehr viel höher es wird geschätzt dass
sie im Durchschnitt doppelt so hoch sind
wie die vor Saudi Arabien besprechen
hier von mehr als 40 $ pro Barrel aber
das ist noch nicht alles die
internationalen Sanktion und der Mangel
an abnehmen man haben dazu geführt dass
Russland sein Öl ein Länder wie Indien
und China mit Preis Nachlässen von bis
zu 35 $ gegenüber dem Weltmarktpreis
verkaufen muss die Umleitung der
russischen ölverkäufer aufmerkte die so
weit von den produktionsquellen entfernt
sind die China oder Indien führt
außerdem dazu dass viel längere
Vorlaufzeit und damit höhere
Logistikkosten verbunden sind um es mal
aufzuschlüsseln 40 $ Förderkosten 35 $
handelsrabatt und höhere Logistikkosten
bedeuten dass Russland bei einem Verkauf
unter 80 € praktisch kein Geld mehr mit
seinen Ruhe verdient und könnt ihr
erraten wie hoch der Preis für ein
Barrel der Sorte brennt kurz vor der
Ankündigung der Öl war genau er hat die
80 Dollar Marke berührt die drastische
Konjunkturabkühlung in China und die
allgemeine Verschlechterung der
westlichen Volkswirtschaften ließen den
Ölpreis und fast 20% fallen von 100
Dollar im Juli auf 80 Dollar Ende
September und das war gerade für
Russland ein schwerer Schlag aber mit
der produktionskürzung haben sich die
Dinge wieder geändert
ja Saudi-Arabien wird mehr Geld pro
Barrel verdienen aber es wird auch
weniger barrels fordern und verkaufen
der Unterschied wird positiv sein aber
nicht zu groß für russland hingegen
machte Anstieg der Ölpreise einen
enormen Unterschied unter 80 $
Marktpreis pro barrele brennt verdient
der Camel praktisch nichts macht sogar
miese und vergessen Sie nicht dass die
ölprofile im Jahr 2021 55% aller
russischen Staatsausgaben gedeckt haben
mit anderen Worten Washington vor den
Kopf zu stoßen und die Position der OPEC
plus zu stärken und vom Krieg zu
profitieren haben die Petra Monarchien
am Golf diesmal beschlossen sich
zumindest vorerst in Wirtschaftskrieg
eindeutig auf die Seite moskauzustellen
und das gilt nicht nur für Saudi Arabien
die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate
beispielsweise haben die
produktionskürzung ebenfalls freundlich
unterstützt vielleicht hat es auch etwas
damit zu tun dass du beides neue Maker
für reiche Russen ist der neue modische
Zufluchtsort für russische Oligarchen
die ihren Reichtum nicht mehr im Westen
genießen können 21 September 2022 großen
fliegen nach Dubai Ticket teilweise
steigen auch 5000 Dollar da die
Spannungen wegen der nuklearen Bedrohung
zunehmen seit dem Beginn des Krieges in
der Ukraine sind draußen und vor allem
russische Millionäre nach Dubai geeilt
und Immobilien zu kaufen Unternehmen zu
gründen und ihr Vermögen in Sicherheit
zu bringen in den Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten zum Beispiel sichert dir der
Kauf einer Immobilie im Wert von 200.000
€ eine Aufenthaltsgenehmigung für drei
Jahre größere Investitionen können die
natürlich noch viel längere
zeitsicherheit geben und obwohl die
Dinge für die großen nicht mehr so
einfach sind wie früher vor allem wenn
es um Finanzgeschäfte geht gelingt es
ihnen Dubai als eine ihrer neuen
operationsbasen zu nutzen das trägt
natürlich zu einem neuen goldenen
Zeitalter für die Stadt bei ihr kennt
den alten Spruch Geschäft Geld steckt
nicht und es sieht so aus als hätten die
Araber zunächst eine sehr gutes Geschäft
gemacht ob das aber auch in Zukunft noch
so sein wird das steht auf einem anderen
Blatt aufgepasst
das Spiel
[Musik]
einer der größten Fehler den Diktatoren
und Autokraten machen ist dass Sie die
Karten diese in der Hand halten immer
überbewerten das liegt in der Natur der
Sache da sind in der Regel von kriechen
umgeben sind und in einer Art Blase
Leben in der ihr Wort gesetzt ist
riskieren sie am Ende oft mehr als Sie
sollten genau das ist Diktaturen wie ist
er dann Hussein nur einmal dafi oder
jüngster Zeit bleibt immer passiert
jetzt könnte den saudischen Staatschef
Mohammed bin Salman etwas ganz ähnliches
passiert und warum nur weil diese
jüngste Schritt sehr deutlich macht das
Saudi-Arabien keiner Weise mehr ein
verlässlicher Partner für den Westen ist
die Ölproduktion in den USA und den Rest
der Welt wird in den nächsten Jahren mit
ziemlicher Sicherheit stark ansteigen
während sich die Entwicklung alternative
Energien einschließlich der Kernkraft
ebenfalls beschleunigen wird mit anderen
Worten der Schritt könnte die
zukünftigen Gewinde des landeswählen
gleichzeitig ist dem militärische
Zusammenarbeit mit den USA für das
Königreich unverzichtbar nicht nur um
Zugang zu modernsten Rüstungsgütern zu
haben und sich im Falle eines Konflikten
Iran verteidigen zu können sondern auch
um Tausende von Arbeitsplätzen zu
erhalten die im Land geschaffen wurden
[Musik]
und wenn der Krieg in der Ukraine etwas
deutlich gemacht hat dann das ist wenn
es um hochmoderne Ausrüstung geht keine
Alternative zu westlichen und
insbesondere US-amerikanischen
Lieferungen gibt vor allem Saudi-Arabien
und seit Jahren erzählt dass es
gigantische Summen investieren wird um
seine Wirtschaft zu diversifizieren
damit das auch wirklich passiert muss
das Land mit den reichsten Ländern der
weltwirtschaftlich zusammenarbeiten das
heißt mit westlichen Unternehmen und
Maßnahmen wie die drosseln oder
Ölproduktion tragen nicht im Geringsten
zu diesem Ziel bei und was ist mit
Russland nur die Luft aus dem möglichen
Rettungsring mit der fördersenkung ist
ziemlich schnell entwickeln die
opec-entscheidung hilft Russland
langfristig nicht und verantwortlich
dafür sind die sieben Staaten durch
diese initiiert traf vor kurzem der
Ölpreis der Klingen Kraft und dieser
schadet Russland so sehr dass die
Drosselung der OPEC plus mittlerweile
wie ein Tropfen auf die heißen Stein
wird wie gesagt Russland kannst du so
viel fördern wie es will es wird damit
aber immer weniger Geld verdienen können
russische Öl Einnahmen sinken im
November trotz Produktionssteigerung der
Rückgang wird als Beweis dafür bewertet
dass die westlichen Bemühungen die
Einnahmen des Krems zu schmälern Wirkung
zeigen die Internationale Energieagentur
schätzt das Russland im November etwa
15,8 Milliarden Dollar aus dem Ölverkauf
eingenommen hat der zweiten niedrigste
werde in diesem Jahr nach 14,7
Milliarden Dollar im September trotz
eines Anstiegs der russischen Exporte
auf 8,1 Millionen pro Tag den höchsten
Stand seit April die EEA sagt voraus
dass Russland Ölproduktion im nächsten
Jahr um 1,4 Millionen pro Tag trinken
wird wir haben das alles schon in
unserem letzten Video zum energiekrieg
mit Russland ausführlich erklärt folgt
einfach der Verlinkung oder schaut auf
unseren Seiten nach einem Bild das euch
an Game of Thrones erinnert klar ist auf
jeden Fall dass die Petro Monarchien die
super macht USA jetzt schon mehrfach
herausgefordert haben und zwar nicht nur
durch die Bevorzugung ihres Rivalen
Russland sondern auch noch in anderen
größeren China
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Anfang Dezember besuchte ich auch hier
war das Timing hochgradig brisant die
Saudis rollten Ski den roten Teppich aus
was mit dem großen Empfang verglichen
wurde Rede ehemalige US-Präsident Donald
Trump bei erhielt im Gegensatz zum
Besuch des amtierenden US-Präsidenten
Joe Biden Anfang dieses Jahres arbeitet
nach dem strategischen Kalkül das ist
Peking Entgegenkommen muss das
inzwischen ein unverzichtbarer
Wirtschaftspartner ist im Jahr 2021
beliefen sich die Exporte des
Königreichs nach China auf über 50
Milliarden Dollar was mehr als 18 % des
gesamten Export Saudi Arabiens ausmacht
außerdem Plan Peking Anteile an Saudi
Aramco zu erwerben dies ist jedoch nicht
nur auf die Arabien beschränkt denn
weitere Golfstaaten scheinen ihre
Beziehung zu China und auch zu Russland
zu vertiefen der Vorteil der Chinesen
sie kritisieren keine
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und möchten
sich nicht in innere wie äußere
Angelegenheiten ein zu schmutzig sie
auch sein mögen auf der anderen Seite
ist Saudi Arabien in den USA gegenüber
jedoch nicht vollkommen gleichgültig
Bensheim man weiß ist sie ein wichtiger
Partner bleiben müssen aber er hat auf
die harte Tour gelernt dass man sich
nicht ständig auf die Unterstützung der
USA verlassen kann schon vor Jahren
hatten die USA beschlossen ihre
traditionelle militärdominanz im Nahen
Osten zu beenden und die Sicherheit der
Region mehr ihren Partnern zu überlassen
schließlich kostet sowas ja auch eine
Stange Geld die Partner waren bis jedoch
nicht in der Lage diese Aufgabe
zufriedenstellend zu erfüllen sie hätten
sich z.B einen mentrale Reaktion
washingt ins gewünscht gegenüber den
Angriffen schiitischer Milizen auch die
wichtigste auf die Arabien jetzt die
wachsende Bedrohung durch den Iran und
seine bewaffneter in der Region hat bei
den Verbündeten USA im Nahen Osten
Verbitterung hinterlassen sie werfen den
USA vor nicht präsent genug zu sein
deshalb hat die Führung des Landes vor
einigen Jahren damit begonnen mehrere
wichtige Beziehungen in einer
zunehmenden multipolaren Welt zu
entwickeln die nun umkehrbar erscheint
allerdings ist kaum davon auszugehen
dass das militärische Macht Vakuum dass
die USA hinterlassen haben von irgendwem
wieder den regionalen Mächten noch China
ausgeführt werden könnte die Frage
lautet daher was werden die Vereinigten
Staaten letztendlich tun werden sie
ihrem militärischen Rückzug aus dem
Mittleren Osten wieder revidieren und
glaubt ihr dass die jüngsten
us-feindlichen Aktionen der Golfstaaten
rein kommerziellen Charakter sind wie
die Saudis behaupten oder sind sie im
Gegenteil ein politischer Schachzug ein
Wink mit dem Zaunpfahl Erpressung
vielleicht gar ein Schrei nach Liebe wie
immer sind wir auf eure Diskussion zu
diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht auch dass dabei
gelernt habt falls ja gib uns bitte mit
euren Freunden und vergesst nicht
glücklich und keines unser Abos mehr zu
verpassen testet bitte auch
unverbindlich das Angebot unseres
heutigen Sponsors nordpass der für die
visuality Community eine ganz besondere
Aktion bietet bei Abschluss eines 2
jahresaboos bekommst du einen Monat
kostenlos dazu wenn du den Code wieso
alpolitik.de angibst den Link findest du
in der Beschreibung unter diesem Video
natürlich freuen uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
ebenfalls in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]